all right let's go ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to your favorite
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes ladies and gentlemen back at it
again this is uh Eric Griffin yo
favorite podcaster hope I'm your
favorite podcaster but even if I'm not I
really appreciate you guys listening or
watching the show we're not gonna keep
the music gone too long this time
you know a lot of stuff going on in the
world as you already know and there's
been a lot of heavy stuff
people talking and people telling you
what you should and should not say what
you should should not do but the show
also must go on and we're doing that
this week didn't do any woo-woos last
week I had a big very heartfelt opening
about the black lives matter movement
and everything that's going on and what
I feel about it and I am gonna do
another long solo episode about what I
more than I feel that's going on but for
now you know during the coronavirus and
all that I was here as an escape and I
want to continue to be escape for some
people you know it can't be 24 hours of
just thinking about this all the time
you know you need to have a rest you
need to collect yourself and you need to
laugh you need to think about other
things and then you can come back to the
heavy stuff I mean that's just how it
works it's just better for you it's
better for everybody so I don't know if
it's right or wrong if I offend some
people I you know it is what it is I
hope you understand what's going on so
anyways I have a very fun light episode
the great Tony Baker is on we talked
about movies we talked about his career
we talked about his rise and it's
inspirational inspirational stuff you
know he I don't think he even really
wanted to be a stand-up at first so we
talked about all that stuff we get into
a little bit about coronavirus and all
that cuz I recorded this it's a
pre-recorded episode because once again
I keep telling you I didn't know who I
was gonna be able to talk to or when so
I just tried to bank as many as I could
so I'm still releasing some of those and
but again I'm gonna do a solo episode
soon probably the next episode or a
bonus episode just really going into all
the things that I feel about what's
going on so I'd like to have a little
bit of everything sometimes I'm light
sometimes I'm heavy and that's just how
we are as human beings we're we're
layered and so this is one of those
layers of just strictly entertainment
just you know if just as a
escape from everything that's going on
in just you know fun informative episode
about just two guys shooting the [ __ ] so
I hope you enjoy so it's real Chris
[Laughter]
alright anyways ladies gentlemen here he
is the man to miss mr. Tony Baker what's
happening man good to see you
you know what man I was sudden your
other day like man I'll be on your page
for like I'll be on your page like 30
minutes sometimes like you know it's
just me a Cordell I don't know if
there's something about your voice I
don't know if it's something about like
it's obviously the comedy of it like
whatever the situation in these videos
that you make but it's something about
your voice tutor just makes it like you
know you don't even have to see you can
just hear and then you want to see
because you want to know what is he
talking about but it's very good man and
this is like really like you you turn
into that guy like how do you feel about
that it's crazy man because you know I
did it I did my first one in like 2013
just to do it for fun I thought it was
funny yeah and then I did another one
and then nothing really you know it was
just I did those two videos and then
when I reposted one like the 20 maybe 15
16 right I think 2016 and then uh maybe
2015 then it went viral I was like oh
let me keep these going yeah and then a
million followers later you know yeah
but you know what the crazy thing about
it is just this business is so weird
that like whatever you set out and you
think you wanna you want to make it
because of cuz of a you know right and
then BCD you know you don't even think
about these things and it could be one
of those you know cuz you know you you
always wanted to be a stand-up I mean I
don't even know that actually it was
what stand-up like your main thing that
you oh no no actually actually I wanted
to act I wanted to be actor in there I
was like man let me think of all those
stand-up comedians that transition in
acting
hoes like man seems like a good way to
get noticed is to do stand-up and then I
was like let me try stand-up but yeah I
did it one time at the hi-hi and I fell
in love with it immediately acting is
second and it's like I just want to get
on a TV show or get a good acting role
just so I can feel the club's up right
right it's fun and you know they okay
it's funny you say that because the
funny thing now is this other thing that
you're doing which is acting is voice
actor right it's gonna still it's gonna
be the thing that's going to end up
filling the club's up yes it's so
strange right it's just a bit you can be
like we were probably around the same
age so it's like you know we're not 40s
right how old are you I'm 42 I'll be 43
next no so I'm older than you but it's
like that's still around the same where
we remember the old school ways of stand
out where it was like right you know you
you were a good comic comedic act and
then the next thing you know you got on
some late night show and then you got a
sitcom and then that was that was the
end of it you know you just boom right
boom but I mean like there's so many
different ways to make it right now that
it's like there's no blueprint anymore
no this is the Wild West West it's crazy
right yeah anything goes anything can
pop anything can make you anything can
change your life whether if you and the
video games on the side you could blow
up from video games they're like oh you
don't stand up to yeah and then you can
blow up from that you're making money
from this and there's just like YouTube
I'm opening boxes it's like anything can
happen now yeah I know it's like it's
but uh but element of it is like trying
to catch that kind of catch down viral
which is so which is so ironic that
we're in this coronavirus you don't I
mean it's like yeah it's like we want
our careers to like be to spread like
Coronas apparently spread right right we
need to get fast cuz my you know my [ __ ]
some I feel like mine's like
chicken pox you know you get it once in
the nest everything is the Wild West
Nile anything can happen
the altars stand up itself remains pure
just like the all of it is so like
weather weather weather people come to
you by different like avenues when they
get in there to see you live you still
have to be good on that stage right I
don't you know what I I don't know if I
I used to feel that way you know I
really used to feel that way and what I
and then and I thought I think that my
attitude has changed because we might
look at it as comics and be like there's
a certain way stand up should be done
you know we just feel that way even even
if that's a wrong feeling there's a
certain way there's a purity we sui sui'
think we they stand up needs to have
right
I realize that has nothing to do with
putting butts in the seats yeah it has
nothing to do with actually why fans
like you I mean there are people who now
do podcasts okay who say weren't doing
stand-up before and are now doing
stand-up because it's not even stand up
it's just I'm doing a public event I
mean your age you don't even call it
stand-up agent
they're called public appearance agents
right so a lot of people are doing
public appearances and it looks like
stand-up but it's not necessarily this
art form that you're talking about it's
kind of like softball you know what I'm
saying you know you play a softball
it looks like baseball but it's not
really baseball you know it's softball
so ball this all balls hard so I know we
had this kind of old-school mentality
about stand-up comedy but what I'm
realizing is it's really about I think
the first thing is about connecting with
your fans them really appreciating what
you do whether and it don't have to be
this high level stand-up you know right
it just doesn't have to so it's like and
that's how
think that's hard for people for me cuz
cuz I came up when I came up it was
about how we thought it was before it
was like how everybody did it in the
past and so now it's like it's just not
like that anymore
there's all these different ways you
know you got like people who got you
know somebody might have a weird YouTube
video presence and next thing you know
they're like the biggest stand-up in the
world like that type of thing you know
it's like that guy could not about that
mama somebody whatever his name is the
white dude who like you know he's on you
he was he's got these huge FaceTime
Facebook press he was to do that was
that jfl and they booed him and a while
any-any we're getting and then he was
getting into fights with comics whatever
but anyway darren something or other but
anyways yeah he um you know he wasn't a
stand-up he did you know but he just was
doing these characters on YouTube and
FaceTime I mean Facebook and the next
thing you know like people wanted to
come see him so now he hasn't he's a
touring act but I think I think we
should start labeling that that type of
comedy differently didn't then then
stand-up comedy because it sounds like
that guy if you come see him live you
want to see him do those characters so
in essence he sounds like a one-man show
as opposed is just a stand-up comedian
there's nothing wrong with that but the
problem is that they get blurred because
we're performing in the same places
exactly so it's like yeah so the people
are confused so it's like because when I
say stand-up comedian I automatically
think of people that stand up there they
tell the jokes they yell yes so this
that the third and then you know you got
you got the people like him we're doing
characters up there you got people that
are doing the podcast live where it's
kind of a laid-back flow which is dope -
yeah but but it's a different it's like
the like I love this this podcast grew
call eight oh eight oh five south oh
yeah those are the guys are um those are
the guys from wiling out I love that
because it's a it's a it's a
free-flowing
why they get couches up there is just
like a free four
all of just pure whoever put that
together they say the kappa i'm say they
capitalized on the the the technology is
climate and took advantage you know and
then now they're out there like they
sell out and like yeah but it's but you
know it's like synergy the some of the
parts are worth you know the the parts
are worth worth more than the whole you
know what I mean I mean always worth
more than the sum of its parts is really
what I mean synergy right you know
because maybe those particular guys
wouldn't be huge selling acts but if
they had done in themselves in the in a
way that we're saying you're supposed to
do it and they just right let's get
together let's use the the fame from
this and then let's start a podcast and
then all these things came together and
now they out here you know right and I'm
sitting back here like damn did I miss
the boat I'm not trying to figure out
the way and then I started a podcast and
this seems to see what happens and it's
just you know I don't know it's
interesting it's just it's just
interesting to like intellectualize
what's happening in the comedy world to
try to figure out what suits me what's
best for me and we don't even know
because you might do something the next
thing you know like you like your
situation it's like you just said I'm
doing these things I think of funny and
then everybody's like more so luckily it
was something that I enjoyed initially
because that's what it's all about me
like what do we enjoy that we can keep
doing it consistently yeah and then
consistency is the main ingredient man
so you know as like ethnic comics you
know
urban you know you I wouldn't even
consider you a urban comic you know what
I mean I don't know it's you know what's
crazy is like I think then when you're
not white you have to have a label oh
yeah it's like you have to have some
kind of like it can't just be like oh
the comedian such-and-such
it's like oh my comics get that
they know they never get the extra label
later we do know or the L and then and
then though the other than like the
black comics become like the superstar
you know like right he gets comic but
that's the only time that they're like
oh just but just regular white dude this
be just oh this guy's a cop you know
comment it's just it's weird but like so
but but what do you think your audience
is though
you know what man based on based on the
people that they show up to the shows
and stuff like that usually black crowd
majority black a lot of couples come
through a lot of I would say 24 to light
early 50s
predominantly white in the 30 range but
like I see just you know I see the young
and I see like the older side I see a
lot of animal lovers pulling up oh
that's crazy
yeah so it's just like you know we watch
a lot of family like a lot of families
show up because man
I watch my i watch your videos with my
kids and they show up so so you get
those have you gone clean oh no no I'm
not saying I'm knockin do I can do clean
cuz like when I was on tour with keV on
stage we were doing a clean show because
keV is clean but I still I still cut
I've always been pg-13 no got you got
you like not to you know if I miss my
mom but occasionally I'll throw it in
there is there a part of you just
thinking like maybe you should just go
clean so you can like and then and then
you would be like cuz then you talk
about families for sure families would
show up like like Gabriel you know what
I mean like he got like a there's like
nine year olds in his crowds you know I
mean like he he he he sets it up where
the whole family can come grandma yeah
you know that a four year old and he
just makes the show fun like that I mean
it seems to be very profitable too right
I didn't even notice he was clean like
that you just said he is clean I don't
wanna get stuck in that yeah but why do
you think it's stuck tell me why you
feel like it's being stuck because of
the way the way I the way I operate
comedic ly and creatively I like to be
able to venture into different things
just say what I want without having to
be like
I can't say that I can't no I can't say
that I can't go here I can't talk about
sex I can't do this I can't do that
weather but if I keep it like neutral in
terms of I can go here there I leave to
us clean because a lot of times I don't
need the extra customs or whatever yeah
yeah I know what you mean but just like
now I gotta be able to talk about what
because I've done cruise ships man to me
too
yeah and and and when I'm restricted I
just hate the feeling of leg but I don't
know we only feel restricted because
like this is a part of our vernacular
like it's sort of like how we talk and
everyday life for me see I've started to
notice that myself like so sometimes I'm
on stage and if I know I should be
cleaner like you're looking at at the
crowd and you might be like wow this is
psych this is seven o'clock show on a
Sunday let me you know but then like I
go so then I'll say a joke that I
normally say [ __ ] three times well and
then I go maybe I don't need to say [ __ ]
you know right and then like you don't
and then you still get a similar laugh
and you say to yourself well don't man
maybe I don't need too much as I do
because I realize I am so natural on
stage like naturally meaning to say I'm
being myself as much as I can and I like
I like to curse I like to throw a
[ __ ] in I like to say this you
know I mean like I used to give you
trouble you will say like stop come on
women [ __ ] I said I'm not gonna know
I call everybody [ __ ] I just like say a
bit right it's just sound my voice [ __ ]
you know right you don't fat [ __ ] you
know whatever it is big [ __ ] like I
just I just love saying whatever
something with [ __ ] sounds great you
know but now you sometimes you just you
look at it you go maybe I don't need to
say that then you get used to it I think
it doesn't feel like a hindrance then I
don't feel like you know it just becomes
a natural thing where cuz there are some
people that just they just don't curse
like that and yeah they seem to be the
ones doing the best oh man they clean up
and like a life for me or not let me
rephrase let me rephrase when I say when
I say clean like I I don't need the
customer I don't need the customs like
if I if people wanted me to not curse I
can do that
but I need the freedom to talk about any
topic that one you got you it's like if
I want to talk about sex I want to be
able to go there without having to worry
I can keep it clean cuz where it was but
the subject matter is very secure see
that's very interesting because that's
that's the distinction that like
sometimes you don't know you know you
know cuz cuz sometimes I've even been in
places where they go oh we don't mind if
you curse but please don't talk about
you know sass like sex is the word
that's this yeah and then the way you
you would talk about it you know but
it's like but like I don't even find
myself you know being like you know
didn't you open a [ __ ] up and then you
know it's like I don't know I just I
don't know man I mean I get it it's like
like when the Super Bowl the halftime
show you know there were two sides of
people that were like you know I was
great fun inappropriate about it I
thought there's other people who were
parents who were like look when I turn
on the Super Bowl I don't want to have
to worry about I gotta like cover my
kids eyes because these latina booties
are just jiggling all over the place and
so right because you know you don't mean
so it's like what makes something dirty
or dirty comedy you know it's a agree
what you're saying it's not just the
curse words right right right
yeah it's that subject matter and it's
funny how we pick and choose like what's
the offense like yeah oh keep the kids
away from the sex and the booty jiggles
but then you don't know why your kids
watching like a action movie where
people are getting killed and broke off
and murdered and you know it's like cuz
I know I was guilty of that as a father
I was like yeah my kids can watch bad
boys too but then if it was like a sex
scene in the you know good that's weird
right yeah cuz I would tend to look at
the action scenes there's more fantasy
like y'all know y'all can't be doing
this within the second very much happen
so it's just like yeah but that's like I
think I think that's an American thing I
think we have a real big hang-up
on sex I mean you go to Europe and you
can see a soap commercial with titties
at eight o'clock yeah and they just like
you know it's it's why are we so why do
you think we're so scared of the human
form I don't know I feel like that that
kind of hung over from the American
society trying to break away from the
European you know aesthetic and becoming
more all we grind America is all about
family and God and religion and you know
we're gonna keep it
wholesome and you know you have a gun
but you know keep your woman covered and
you know you have a family and it's just
I'll cover that body up and you look at
it yeah we seem to be scared of I think
I think you know what's weird is I think
we're scared of in particularly this
like the female form like oh my god we
want it covered up we wanted you know we
wanted hidden we want it like you know
we only want to breathe out when we want
it you know right weird feeling right
yeah everybody loves the female form
even though the women yeah but they
scared of it you know it's funny I feel
like in comedy we very much are you know
you know it's funny is like so like when
you have a male a tie personality comic
onstage like Chris D'Elia for instance
you know so his sexuality is enhancing
his performance because the women are
out there like I want to go I love you
so funny and handsome and in there and
the dudes are like oh I want to be this
dude right you know yeah
but then put a hot chick onstage and her
sexuality is not enhancing her
performance but somehow a roadblock to
people really connecting yeah you're
right isn't it weird
yeah I've noticed that I've noticed like
wonder when you get the the hot female
comedian they get up there they're just
talking about dating and stuff it's just
a different reaction to that
supposed to like you know unattractive
you know maybe like a big a big girl get
so dim and crazy like I don't know why
they got near me yeah like a fan blade
like a fat black woman they don't even
count her as a woman crazy no they don't
feel threatened in the audience that she
can take my man right here maybe the
women are cou you like this you feeling
this ready so it's like so messed up I'm
just doing anything an observation I
don't know I'll have to ask a female
comic I'll have to have a hot topic on
the show and be like hey how's this for
you but just my observation it feels
like that it feels like I always say
like like I was when I think about
myself I go I have to be funny you're
like I can't you know when I go onstage
they not they not going oh I do handsome
they going funny it's like you know I've
seen like the handsome comments come
onstage and I've heard girls to be like
the first thing they say is oh he's so
hot you know you were listening like
who's there so so what it becomes as the
comedy becomes like an extra you know
yeah it's just feels like that in
comparison they think about you though
you look like you're funny though
because when I see you Ivan for the
first time I saw you I was my eldest
dude look like he but to be funny I
don't know what is yeah so people just
look like a serial killer
yeah it was right I was right yo this
dude because this certain people would
it be like
you know what I'm gonna sit I'm gonna
listen to what he got to say I'm sitting
there I'm smiling already okay the
comedies right here I get it I'm already
laughs I know but I did but I know what
you're saying about like what someone
like an attractive females on stage and
she starts talking about stuff
like if you're a dude in a crowd and you
lose your girl I mean what depending on
how secure your relationship is as a
dude you might not be able to you know
laugh the way you want to laugh or even
boy you know what I mean it's like no my
girl we were sitting here watching she
puts on this necklace Netflix show right
it is all surfer boys you know misty
surfer dudes your shirts all the stuff
and I was like you watch me when I was a
kid I was like okay so like it's a
double standard because you know okay
cuz I can't be like oh that's what you
want or you you know answer might be yes
but I'm not even thinking that I just
think it's funny the way I deal with it
I was like oh look at you getting all
hot and bothered by these like young you
know really fine with it but like the no
the other way it might not be like that
you know the other way if I put on the
show saw bikini models on you you find
yourself not being able to enjoy it the
way you want to enjoy it because it's
because there's a woman on screen to
your girl is porn if you look if you
look at my girls Instagram if you look
at who she's following yeah she's
following a whole bunch of just bad
chicks they cut up shape booties today
every time I answered her phone she's
gone I'm like she just got this I can do
City over there look at mine it's like
mostly people I actually know in person
or like you know it has to funny that
yes it was just like but I never got
into the following the eye candy women
on Instagram because that's just a
rabbit hole that I don't want to get
stuck in Tony we know your wife is
standing right there it's okay
who you bullshitting right now who you
doing like this you know cuz I never it
was always it was always like that
because I was like man I can't be
following these chicks cuz I I would I
would find myself getting caught in
those rabbit holes sometimes it's just
like women I didn't even follow one I
know they last when I got real serious
with my girl I had to like I think I
unfollowed like 500 people I was looking
like because at first it was like I just
followed people back because they
followed me or I was like when was like
you know especially if I take pictures
with them how to show it swallow the bag
it's good to like you know cuz in it
like spreads and it's like anything and
and girls more popular so it's like
easier to follow girls and have girls
spread to love and then you just find
yourself looking at again you're just
looking at eye candy so then you know
yeah and then and then Instagram was
snitching you know what I mean snitching
like you you know you've like in
pictures and then there's like a whole
thing there's a whole and they should
have just called it the thirsty page you
know I mean write a thirsty area you go
to Anna's like damn look it up why why
do you put my business out on the street
and then like so you know so they got
rid of that thankfully mm-hmm but but
then the other thing that they had on
there which wasn't cool is like so let's
say you and I are following the same big
titty chick mm-hmm if I like her picture
you'll see when you go to the page it
says Tony Baker oh yeah so so what was
happening there would be like if I'm
following the same person is my girls
falling cuz they like to follow a lot of
girls too then it shows up Eric Griffin
light so then I was like yeah so didn't
it turn into a thing sounds like you
know what I just you know what I do now
I just I don't like you know you know
she's you know what you know I just pick
up my fault like this and I go I like
that
IUD you don't need like it you don't
need visual confirmation that you
appreciate what you're looking at I just
read just looking up yeah
imagine if like porno sites were like
that like a pornhub you had to they do
have likes and stuff on there I think
how they do now if they have if they
have a system where you can see
everything you like don't nobody do what
you like oh yeah because we see so much
porn where was that one scene yeah yeah
that'd be that'd be yeah yeah but you
can't have the beneficials nowadays what
have you been watching since during this
thing I mean we haven't listened you
know what this is my first podcast and I
didn't open up with talking about how
you doing it no corona like I saw
Whitney Houston talking about that
Whitney Houston Whitney Cummings target
on her thing about like everybody's
asking about but I mean this is what's
going on right now but like how how are
you getting along the money lost in the
lack of stage I love this because I
needed I needed to break to just sit
down and just you know I'm still doing a
lot here in terms of like content but
like this just being in the house and
like chill I'll be playing video games
with my son's heavy and like oh that's
good for you I think I feel like I've
been spending less money I know exactly
what you saying
and not just because we're thinking
about money it's just a natural like I'm
going to the grocery store I'm shopping
for food I'm cooking I don't cry just
cause it was just going out to eat all
the time and just like you need yeah
yeah we know without bra let me get this
it it's like so I've noticed my spending
has decreased the gas money of course
and so the silver lining for me is just
you know the family time I've been not
eating out as much my weight is going
down yeah me too yeah so it's just life
and I'll see you being there cooking
team the home-cooked meals oh man
I always a better thing for us because
you know what's going to me in the in
the meal mat but do not find myself
acting like I totally getting I'm acting
like turning into my mom from but you
know because like when I cook I cook I'm
like when I finish cooking I'm ready you
know yeah and I'm gonna get your ass
yeah you like you know I'm told you put
the phone down you know I did it so it's
like it's really interesting like yeah
so yeah I've been cooking on Instagram
people like that you know that I've been
like you I go to this one company Sun
basket they're not really a sponsor but
if you like I could give a referral code
and you get $40 off and I get $40 off so
I don't even need them to make me an
official sponsor I'm just like cooking
and being like putting it up and being
like use martyr and people have used it
because it's actually really cheap it's
only like it's only like 10 or 11
dollars per meal and it serves - oh wow
yes of course you can increase you can
say give me enough to serve for give me
enough to say you know you know and
it'll be like more but when you think of
the cost of like if you're if you're
saying to me that this is like six seven
dollars per person for a whole ass you
know a perfectly cut caloric intake meal
yeah that's real cheap yes I'm trying to
but there's a lot of them like that
there's Sun you just look up
pre-prepared pre like they have
precooked ones they have ones that like
I think blue apron is one of those two
blue apron but they'll give you
everything so let's say you cooking like
chicken curry
yeah they'll give you the exact amount
of curry sauce you need and a little
thing and they have the garlic
everything's there you have to chop
things up you use like salt and pepper
from Austrian oil and you put it
together and then they give you the
instructions and you find yourself and
then you find yourself using those
recipes later so now yes you
cook some potatoes the way they say once
now you know oh I know how to cook
potatoes now so potatoes just go so I do
recommend but if you're gonna use some
basket miss you get my referral code
dude they got a vet I don't know if they
have vegan I think they have vegan but
it's vegetarian you could do anything
you want you can do I'm doing a paleo
one so it'll be like a meat and a
vegetable but they got so many different
types of low carb high carb whatever you
want they have all the different like
things and they just give you everything
you need so you know what I like about
is you not wasting anything you know
right you know you're trying to cook a
meal and they say look at the recipe and
it says like whatever you go okay I
gotta go to store you can't still get
one you got to get like six onions and
you got to get you know you gotta get
all the things and then that you like
but one but once you start cooking
you realize you're always cooking like
it's not it's not like you're cooking
one me you're cooking all your meals
then that was something to get used to
so I cooked rice and I said oh [ __ ] that
was dope and then it was like oh [ __ ]
there's five now I hope there's another
feel supposed to come yeah you know so I
don't know yes I've been doing now now
do you think you think you go cook more
once we get our freedom yes for you I
don't think because I actually enjoyed
that whole process the cooking and
making into cleaning up it's like a
whole thing like it's a whole like you
know like I don't know it's meditative
if you know what I mean like oh man you
know he's great
it's a good thing man but I've been
doing that too I just been playing video
games but not twitch oh they do what do
you play I play Modern Warfare right now
I've been playing it every night oh man
what do you got a gig I got to get you
on we got to play the other and I just
I'll send you this little thing where
you could put your face on my screen and
we can just twitch together oh I I
bought it on Xbox but I've been talking
it also on ps4 I just downloaded free on
ps4 it's a free game and it's so fun I
mean I play what I do is like I played
with fans so I just like okay I play
like like in the quads with
and I'll be like yeah first four to get
in first three to get in will go and I
just did the right boom boom boom and I
boom and they love it you know and I'm
on their Twitter stuff so you know yeah
we got to play that's a good I got do
all filters let's do that okay I'm glad
to know you know you know who love plays
Ron Funches plays oh yeah okay like me
you rob was running like a trios or
something that we'll find out right yeah
I'll do that
yeah I'll tell you I've been playing
every night for the past like week and a
half and actually I ended up buying the
game just so I could do the multiplayer
to co-op and we've been playing I've
been up at 5:00 6:00 in the morning just
yeah I know this holy what have you been
watching on TV what have you been
catching up on what's your what your
have you been like that's something I've
been doing I just been catching up on
all kind of shows and stuff you know I
watch first of all finished
Ozark season three I was good finish
that I feel like it was the stronger
season so far you think I think so I
think it goes 3-1 - yeah I got - I don't
think - is this stronger so I think
Matheny we're still trying to fit you
know the first season that something is
always sometimes the best because this
is that fresh idea in their head and
they executed it now it's like alright
continue the world
tell me more like this world and they
sometimes have trouble doing that and
then they [ __ ] together season 3 yeah
like a dip and season 2 a lot of the
time yeah just come show because it's
not as fresh but go ahead what else you
bright watching that I really I always
go back to movies man I always just
watch movies yeah was like what movies
have you been I'm even watching old
movies are you catching up on any of
these new ones I always go to the old
joints cuz I just can't help it like
I've been doing I've been watching
movies on my life so I was bleed I love
I was oh the first blade or the first
blade is just a perfect movie I think I
think Wesley Snipes is bleed and Robert
Downey jr. is Iron Man are the only two
characters
who
whose interpretation of those comic book
characters surpass the comic book
versions oh oh you know what I agree
with you on that
um blade one but I also really enjoyed
blade - I enjoyed bleh - but blade three
got that like go kill yourself you know
I mean like like like sometimes like
Ryan Reynolds in that was just like I
was like what is happening Brooks he was
so much just pushing that comedy to the
point it's like oh my god he finally got
I think he was like that a 10 and then
finally for not daredevil what's the one
he had Deadpool ten in Blade 3 he got it
down to a four and that's still a nine
for the rest of us blade three they just
really fumbled it out there but yeah
blade one or two blade was really good I
really I you know what that's one of
those movies I could just throw on at
any time - oh man the first the first
half of blade is just perfection just
how do they get to it immediately they
already said blade it's already
established right on who he is
vampires like oh [ __ ] blade is here
that's our intro
it was just rapid fire after that well
you know what's also good about blade
that opening you're talking about not to
cut you off but I just want to just
because oh my god what was that
that girl is like a famous porn star oh
yes Tracy Lord
Traci Lords exactly Tracy Lord that was
Traci Lords in like from our childhood
Traci Lords was like this famous
underage like it was all exposed and she
was 16 and other [ __ ] so it was like it
was like a seedy underbelly to her be
that character it added to the the
ambiance of the dislike the vampires are
just terrible
you know to me is gritty is anything
goals it's like and this was our intro
to the movie layoffs Tracey low I know
and then I wore them to the club and
then a little little blade trivia is you
know when they get to the club that guy
that's opening the door that was a lousy
her real boyfriend oh really in real
life that was Traci Lords boyfriend so
that's why inside info yeah but yeah
blade was good I really enjoyed blade of
the Marvel movie like that's a Marvel
movie even though we're in a Marvel
movie the way we know it now but Ryan it
was a Marvel movie so I really I really
and I don't know how this new blade I
like that guy but he seems a little old
to be blade I feel like he he has the
visual for for that type of character
like a cuz he he can look like a vampire
like he's darkly tall I can see him like
you know with the blade but he looks too
much like Wesley Snipes to me so just it
just makes you seem like you know you
know he's like yeah just like the same
thing it's like but it's not the same so
I don't like to go in like Carmel now or
something or go you know to me like make
goals go with Rick Fox or like you know
say like he can't be 645 he gotta be
midnight microphone yeah I suit I know
what you saying so you got blade and
then I totally agree with you about
Robert Downey playing Tony Tony yeah it
carried it actually carried the whole
series yes I know I'm just like he is
Iron Man he is I even though I'm a big
it since the 60s Robert Downey jr. is
Iron Man
yeah such a well Wesley Snipes is blade
is just like those guys they're gonna
have to recast Iron Man eventually but
Robert Downey jr. made the character
itself more popular ya want me to kill
him you know I got teared up in the
movie in the laughs oh yeah I thought so
my soul mouse like it was good man let
me tell you something about endgame real
quick I said that was my favorite movie
of 2019 because and I I say infinity war
is better but in game the the hold the
movie has a hold and the whole movie
going experience was just the most fun
I've had in the movie theater and since
I was a kid probably yeah
like it was electric cuz we saw it on
opening weekend we were in a random city
we piled in there and it was like we
were at a sporting event yeah but that's
too weird but that's ten years in the
making though yeah oh yeah - mmm you
know and I and I just agree with you I
like to end game better than infinity
war oh I just like cuz I I felt like I
was getting kind of bored within game
because it was so long and in the first
you know half of what I was just like
all right guys it was like boom boom
boom
Thanos is coming down I was here yo I'll
tell you my plan my mom I executed look
out man give me these infinity gems it
was like rapid fire he won and then it
went off I was just like yes what I'm
saying to that I was like he was the
hero of the story it was like let me ask
you this because I remember so did you
like black pant yeah like who black
panther I did here's my thing about
black panther because a lot of people
are calling it overrated cuz I cuz it
was here's what I like about Black
Panther now am I
i'ma do the origin story argument here
okay it's
ours oranges stories go it was one of
the strongest comic book story comic
movie origins because we establish it
established so many dope characters
outside of the initial character a lot
of times they they they overshadowed
Black Panther in terms of like the rival
clan leader his youngest sister his
general the villain the other villain in
Klaw
it was just like the total ensemble and
world bill was just really dope okay
like I could not disagree with you more
I mean I could disagree with you more I
would find a way to disagree with you
more first of all civil war captain
america civil war the version of black
panther in that movie far surpassed this
[ __ ] that they created in the black 3
agree he had a purpose you know he and
then he had the redemption in the end to
realize that revenge wasn't gonna he
just was a stronger more established
character and then another movie online
who's this guy who is this guy right
okay and then and then i agree with that
and then okay so this other clan leader
he has been loyal to the crown for 20-30
years whatever
mmm-hmm and all of a sudden some
stranger could come in and make him turn
no way became a hooter
the other the other leader the guy with
the rhinos when his what you know the
Rhino guy oh well that but they
establish why he switched what it wasn't
enough it wasn't it wasn't enough
because should be Jay something else why
would they only be one black hunter why
what what you mean they have the ability
to make everybody in Wakanda Black
Panther that's tradition though right so
you talkin okay so you're talking about
a society that respects tradition right
why would that guy turn
I know why he turned here's the thing I
mean let me paint a picture on why he
would hand it for me because that movie
is terrible
okay it's not even it's not even in the
top it's not even in the top ten Marvel
movies okay I can name you ten movies in
the Marvel Universe
that's better than that movie but that
was the soul but that's all they ever
seen you just said an MCU man that that
movie was in like that movie was like on
par with the first Captain America which
was like she was like soar to know
because they were building the tension
between him and the general because he
wanted he wanted his father's killers he
wanted his father's death avenge yeah so
it was like yo let me let me get claw
let me let me get in on that claw
takedown and so they were they were
building that river he's like yeah we're
gonna get caught let me get in on the
Koala takedown we gonna get the club let
me go with you and so here's a guy
here's a guy that comes out of nowhere
this the job done breathe claw in this
and he has the wakandan bloodline so of
course he's gonna be like I like the way
this guy's moves
- Tyler lied to me it was like y'all we
gonna get close we gonna get close but
you can't brush that to the side
wouldn't bring me along this guy comes
in this is one penis but this is what
I'm saying about the Black Panther
version in that movie I needed the Black
Panther version that was defending gonna
you know to avenge his father's death
where's that guy oh yeah he's getting
beat up on it on a mountain like you
have the most advanced technical Conda
it's just come on come on this is this
Marvel storytelling right Dino's about
what kinda get out of here
the whole appeal of wakanda it's just a
secret world of just with that but
that's just true to the comic book right
there yeah okay you can't fault the
movie for that I just I just it just
wasn't one it wasn't my favorite of the
Mar I am like I said I thought I think I
think Civil War was was better I think I
think the Winter Soldier was better one
of the best ones poetry both of it three
of the Avengers were better you know
loved the first one and the last two
that Ultron won I could do without that
one
the first must be real about the first
avenge huh the first minutes was shaky
is it yeah but they had to but here's
the thing though the first 30 was I've
got to add that big sequence I mean the
thing is they had to establish how these
people are gonna come together and what
has been happening because they've been
working on it for eight years before
that you know ever every movie they were
like hinting towards it here's Nick Fury
here's you know I here we go this is
gonna happen here's how it's gonna
happen here house you know and then they
finally had to put it together but look
yeah okay so they started shaky but they
ended well
like the likely one of the best scenes
in the whole MCU is the first time you
saw all of them standing there and the
camera pans around all the Avengers for
the first time you know what I mean and
you've seen them standing there it's
like Hong Catherine miracle yeah you
know and I was like because I used to
collect The Avengers comic book right
yes a toast so to see these guys on
scream like that for the first time was
like amazing to me in the final battle I
was just like my head exploded
yeah and that's why I loved in that end
game how they kind of went back to it
you know yeah give us a he finally got
to say Avengers Assemble it was just it
was on it cradles beautiful yeah so if
you if you look they stay in the
traditional aspect as long as they could
because even though even though we know
kill monger was the villain and he did
shady [ __ ] to get where he got to get in
there
they still honored the fact been he was
a legit bloodline
they lied it kept the secret that to
child as dad there's some shady [ __ ]
right they swept that under the rug so
it was just like but we still gonna
follow the traditional guidelines the
general had the stain because so Charlie
lost the one-on-one fight so they had
the island ad and it was just like uh
the traditions and so character was so I
thought that I wanted to see more about
that character I thought that's which
one the the main advantage orden okay
kill mugger yes I thought that his
character was so much more interesting
than the whole movie like to know that
like like let's let me see what you know
the way someone grows up in darkness the
way someone has this like chip on their
shoulder and like right it's like they
turned him into our cartoon character in
the end but like leading up to that I
wanted to know more and then it was like
cuz that came out of nowhere that he
then he you know he kills the white guy
that we think is the real villain and
the heat and then you're like oh wait
what's going on here and then he is like
next thing you know he's King I just
think this story was muddy I don't think
it was a well-told story I don't think
this went together well but it's just
one of those things like I don't know if
you're watching black as [ __ ] are you
watching black as [ __ ] you gotta watch
it this is it's a little shaky at first
but this is one great episode where he's
discussing like I'm is it's an episode
about should black people support black
art just because it's black right you
know and and this idea that because of
the political climate why people support
black stuff just because it's black - so
they could so they could feel like and
for sure Black Panther was that was what
was going on during that movie that was
not sadness in my special it was the
white guilt movie of the decade like my
movie today because all white people
were like oh did you oh did you see oh
my god was so good
oh I saw it it was such an important
movie it was the [ __ ] you didn't like
this movie it was actually it was I
I enjoyed it because they're too strong
what I didn't like I tell you what I
didn't like I didn't like the fact that
he just turned into I hate it when they
always fall back on no no let me let me
fight the evil version of myself as a
superhero right let me fight the bad
black pants a man Ironman one Ironman
had to fight Jeff Bridges an iron suit
over here we go
so but his motivation as a villain was
fantastic right it was like I'd it was a
solid nation as a villain is what I'm
saying it's like I would have preferred
to see more about that it's like right
it's like they built up Thanos to the
point where you go I get it
like I love the fact that he was just on
a farm like you know I did it you know
the universe is thriving now thank you
you're welcome
you never mean in the end he believed
you know in the fact that he even like
destroyed the stones because he was like
look I don't want the temptation of
being a guy made to unit because of my
cuz you you know it's like you saw his
planet was destroyed from overpopulation
so that was his motivation all along
that he lost everyone and so he was like
so you could they built that up where
you were like okay you almost like
misguided he need there's other ways how
about you the stones are just removed
pollution you know what I mean how about
the stones and make the planets three
times bigger like how many I mean
there's so many other solutions you
could do with this ultimate power
instead of right how about you shrink
everybody three you know make everybody
like you know half the size make
everybody half the size on the planet so
there's more space on the planet you
know I mean there's so much more with
his uh his thought was like the bees
kill everybody I just think it's
short-sighted and so you have the power
to bring everybody back to like you know
whatever the then then just you know
pollution gone yeah water clean
pollution would have been a bad idea
because there would have came back he
was just like I'm I just obliterated all
that cuz it everything
when you've been doing what it just came
back so he says like you know what I'm
gonna get rid of how about this reusable
energy boom it's like if so he didn't
think this plan through he could have
thought about this plan a little bit
more I'm getting rid of everything and
if you notice I noticed you said you
read comics they took away the element
that he was obsessed with death they
took that out of the home in the comic
book he was obsessed with the with death
yeah so he just wanted to appease death
by killing out half of existence in the
universe
way to get in good graces is about to
kill everybody
yeah overflooded and I'm also glad
speaking of the MCU is like they got
when they put um God ants a lot of water
when they put a spider I'm good I was
glad when Spiderman came in you know and
I'm also glad that they fixed they made
it they worked out that deal between
Sony soon cuz Sony was sucking a bag of
dicks like they just don't know how to
make movies you know they just they
don't they don't neither does the people
that make the DC movies don't know what
they're doing either they should they
should have the lady to make Wonder
Woman just have her take over cuz she
obviously understands how to like tell a
story put the story together film it
properly because the rest of this [ __ ]
is just cuz they like they've dropped
the ball so hardcore you know with
Justice League with Justice League with
all that with the Superman's two members
Batman even though that Batman fight
when he was rescuing yes a mom was
realize the greatest Batman display
agree cinematic Batman display ever he
ever easy
and and it was a homage to the videogame
I don't know if you've ever played the
video game the Batman Arkham Knight you
need to play that that cuz everything he
did in that fight is a homage to that
game he used the grass he used a
disruptor he used the batarangs
he used the grapple you know it's just
is such a great fight you know they but
the thing the thing they dropped the
ball in that movie is they didn't
explain to me
enough no weight at all why Batman
turned why he decided imma kill people
because oh yeah because the thing that
makes Batman who he is is his honor
mm-hmm you know like he can't he is
uncorruptible right you know and that
right there
day day you just if you're a Batman fan
just even though yeah you're just like I
just Batman wouldn't do that the whole
movie I'm going baby I wouldn't do that
right right Batman when he was killing
people he was look at the Dark Knight he
easily could have killed Joker's seven
times yeah every time you don't I mean
so I just did I that was the one thing I
didn't like and I actually I personally
liked Ben Affleck as Batman I thought he
did oh I thought you did a great job all
the hate he was good I'll get this he
was a great he was good that's the best
bad man has ever looked in costume to me
was in Batman vs. Superman is the the
gray black just his whole day the whole
look is my favorite look of Batman on
film so far and that you write that
fight is because even though the
Christopher Nolan Batman trilogy is
great the fight choreography has been
suspect and all three of those well I
did I disagree with you about that those
three in totality are not great I think
that the first one is the best because
it was that to me was the best origin
story of Batman on screen like - really
was a great orator - and it also and
also changed the genre by the way that
was the first superhero movie that was
like a real movie like it was like if it
was like you know the dot flare or
something you know just the way it was
filmed the way Nolan filmed it the way
he took the acting serious it wasn't
cartoony that changed the genre and I
think that was a great origin story for
a Batman movie but like not for no fault
of their own he's left her died you know
like he died and they had to change the
movie like they had to
like the second one have four parts that
to face area was like such a waste of
space and so I think that I think it you
know who know and who knows what part
three would have been if Joker was still
alive you know what I mean right
I think you know cuz they you can't just
change the guy let's get a new Joker all
of a sudden but I guess they could have
because of this latest Joker but alright
you know yeah I don't know man I just
think that like that the Bane one I
thought was ridiculous
you know the baby was easy my least
favorite of the three in the way he went
out don't even get me started on that so
you think the Dark Knight is over eight
that would you just say yes I do think
the Dark Knight is overrated but it's
not because it's only because of gonna
give me another example of something
like you know in gladiator
remember gladiator you know the guy a
guy died in the making of gladiator the
the the guy that was the his the guy
that had Maximus trained as a gladiator
the guy that was the hero yeah that guy
yeah that guy died so I was there
because I was reading about how it was
supposed to change the movie like he
wasn't gonna have a moment where he was
gonna be in the they had to change it
you know when you 100 million in yeah
and somebody dies you wanna honor the
person's death but you are hundred
million so it's like you keep going his
name was Oliver Reed yes yeah yeah so
yeah so what I'm saying is they had to
the movie was still great that's one of
my favorite movies but Danny changing
what I'm saying is cuz I think Heath
Ledger died when they were in the
process of editing the movie or like
still filming they were still gonna
maybe film some stuff I don't know if
that's true or not but I do know that
his death affected the outcome of the
movie I know ya know I think that his
death affected like you know what they
were gonna do it because you remember
this tool is they they knew it was gonna
be a trilogy yeah he only so Joker dies
it has to change how this movie goes
because of what's gonna happen in the
next movie so it affected things in a
way that I thought I didn't think that
they handled it well enough because I
just thought Dark Knight was
too much it's like it's like he was
doing all this stuff and then when I
when I got to the point where they were
on the boats and they had to pick that's
the point where I was like this is too
much you knowing that you're reaching
too far the movie was too long at that
point we're an hour to when you know
more Joker's doing more [ __ ] and then we
still have to deal with to face it just
was too much so I just feel like Dark
Knight was overrated because of that but
not by but by no fault of their own and
then like again the main one was just
ridiculous I have to disagree with you
on the first movie to take it seriously
on the comic book to Maruyama give that
to bleed okay no no III agree but but
here's the thing though like you said
though in Blade it wasn't necessarily an
origin story blade was already blade
oh you mean as far as the origin story
Thomas was an origin story of like
showing how Bruce Wayne became Batman
there isn't a better showing of that
because there's there's a couple
characters in a superhero universe that
everyone knows the origin story just the
common person if you say you know Batman
Superman and spider-man everybody knows
how they became superheroes I even think
spider-man is probably number one you
know he got bitten by a radioactive
spider yeah you know even people know
about Uncle Ben you know what I mean
like Uncle Ben yeah you know so I guess
one of those stories people know like
like how many times we got to see Bruce
Wayne's parents being killed right you
know what I mean that's like okay we
okay we're do you gonna say it cuz cuz
this is what I didn't like about the
Joker there's this latest movie Joker
what came Phoenix is like 55 hmm Batman
in that movie was 10
there was a huge lag so by the time that
but by the time Bruce Wayne becomes
Batman this Joker gonna be he gonna be
88 and like how does he go back he gonna
be old and that was the one part that I
was like I wish they would have just
made Bruce Wayne in college you know I
said but they need but it was like it
said the symmetry of it is the night
that Joker when they're crazy Bruce
Wayne's family dies and that's how you
go keep it I get it I get it but they
get a younger actor but that what came
Phoenix was just spectacular in that
role so you get it right but now they
making a sequel so now I'm like is he
gonna be like a cryo chamber for like 10
20 years and then he comes around is it
gonna be like Austin Powers here's the
question like how is Joker because this
is the second time they tried to they
tried to say the Joker was involved in
the death of yeah Bruce's parents they
did dad in the Jack Nicholson joy he
does Jack Nicholson one and he was like
Jack Nicholson at the time was like in
his 50s or whatever yeah when I go but
being 20 years older than Batman is one
thing you know yeah but when you go see
like 30 40 years older than Batman but
what I'm saying is like so in terms of
like an origin story like that's a great
origin story though that Joker origin
story is fantastic Joker so as a door
that story blade wasn't an origin story
so so that's why I'm saying Batman
Begins is a better origin story Batman
Begins is like you know you see it just
everything made sense you go oh yeah he
trained as a ninja with this secret
organization and he was the best and
that his aunt and I in and in that movie
too you see his honor even in that movie
it started there he's like I'm not gonna
kill this guy we're supposed to be the
good guys and then he went on to be you
know to be Batman you know I mean right
but but he would have got like
coronavirus if it was real because
apparently all this [ __ ] comes from bat
so he was in this cave he would've got
sick and right so back
yeah but I think that was a great or
destroyed it it's not that many really
great origin superhero stories you know
like well you know there wasn't an
origin story though not really
it wasn't our origin story because he
it's true the world was already
established did these are the best
origin stories all right
this recent Joker Batman Begins and the
first Iron Man that was a great gorgeous
story because first Iron Man was though
because the way they set up you believed
the technology and this is another thing
I don't like about black panther so a
meteorite comes like the technology was
too far-fetched like I couldn't wrap my
brain around the nanotechnology like not
the way like an Iron Man you believe
that what he was doing was possible even
though it's not possible but the way
they set it up and showed it you were
like Oh Tony Stark is brilliant and this
is how you would have liked you know but
what's he get into like magic because
that's what Black Panther is it's magic
and then you start to go come on come on
is it magic
yes it's basically so it's a meteorite
match with the Podesta meteorite but
it's all it's all like but that's again
you you gotta could you gotta come at
the source material yeah because this is
where you know we already needed the
vibranium is one I will conduct was so
advanced and secret yeah it's because of
the vibranium that yeah which is Captain
America shield and all of that so yeah
but you come before but again when you
when you when you come up with what you
frozen right now Amin Amin them you let
you uh unfreeze for a second alright but
what were you talking about right the
origin story of black pant or the origin
story of how the I just like I'm okay
with vibranium and not knowing where it
came from and then them using it like
like Tony Stark and his father Howard
Stark them using vibranium is one thing
for
for and also by the way it goes into
like Wolverine and x-men we universe to
like vibranium over in oh my bad yo
forget but again that's one of those
things were as long as you don't know
where it comes from you just know that
it exists that's that's better than
knowing where it came from and then now
you have to be like well how did you
actually do that you know it's like you
know I mean like these flowers and I
don't know I just I'm not I'm so I'm
really anti black panther I just thought
that story was so muddled you know but
again you know what we're coming which
is like over an hour and you know I
think we gonna have to do this again we
don't have to have a part two we really
don't go into like both universes the
MCU and the DC Universe just to see you
know where oh [ __ ] you've really got you
froze again yeah and I lost you for a
sec that's what I'm saying we vote yeah
you were like frozen on sequel this up
yeah yeah we don't have to go again you
know but anyways let me let me let me
just wait I got to get a good let me
just get a good screen to go out with ya
waylay this coming is coming I don't
know why like it's like like somebody's
on the internet or something on both of
our places it's like it's like really
weird like was it was you should have
seen how crisp the picture was and now
all of a sudden it's just not okay here
we go yes you claim aid
yeah you too it's weird I wonder what
that is but don't matter for me be
that's just your reference to my camera
I'm using it looks great it's gonna be
great
Bokke you put another marker alright but
anyways you know what we gonna continue
our conversation about these movie
universes the next time you come on
we'll just strictly talk movies because
I really like talking about movies okay
you know I love that you're a comic book
nerd and you uh-oh
yes so we gotta have to get into that so
this is probably all this part one with
Tony Baker and you know check out Tony
on his Instagram he really does these
really funny
voice-over videos worried like you know
is it could be anything you know he just
he just does the voice-over of the video
that's then the video is already like
either crazy or funny and then he just
just enhances it even more then you get
lost on your page so you know everybody
and I have all the links and all that
stuff up right there and let that expect
you to stay safe I want you to be well
I'm glad that you would you know making
the best of this best of this time with
you and your family and I wish you all
the best in you know i'ma talk to in
like another 10 days and we'll you know
have a part two is going to talk to you
and thanks for being on alright alright
bro all right take care
[Music]